Aznavour brassins shim La Fouine
connaissez-vous le point commun entre
ces quatre artistes ils sont tous
yvelinois de cœur ou d'adoption et pour
ouvrir notre calendrier de Noël 100 %
éelinois voici quatre albums sortis en
2023 à offrir ou à
souffrir tout d'abord teamed up avec les
immortels il nous amemène dans son
univers mélancolique et poétique à 28
ans cette artiste originaire de
Rambouillet affiche une sensibilité
captivante i avec cœur parapluie qui met
le chanson intime et puissante sa voix
unique ses textes poignants brille dans
des titres comme mauvais rêve reflétant
l'âme de cette chanteuse dont la famille
réside toujours à Montini le Bretonneux
Florent PANI avec de BIS des duos
émouvants des reprises à succès conçu en
partie dans son Arre de paix le village
médiéval de Montfort laamort et enfin
dernier album d'un artiste issu des
evelines de Guill en cour plus
précisément c'est hatique avec niya le
rappeur révélé par la série de Canal
Plus validé exprime sa quête de sagesse
et d'évolution
personnelle